- I hear that your mom has been sitting in
on your interviews.
Is that right?
Because you're 14, right?
- [Malia] That is correct.
- [Kelly] Okay.
Is that good? Because I think-
- You know, there are some good instances
and there are some bad
aspects of it, you know?
Like, texting in the middle of practice,
"Fix your face right now, Malia.
Just, like, smile a little bit more,"
and I'm like, "Okay, that's comforting.
Awesome really, really cool."
- Just so you know, I'm 39,
and my mom literally just texted me,
like, tips for me and Blake.
We're being too mean to
each other on The Voice.
Yeah, yeah, she reprimands me at 39.
So, this isn't changing.
- Oh, this is comforting. This is great.
- [Kelly] So just lean in, lean in...
- Lean in to it? Got it. Okay.
- So, does your mom, your
mom is here today, right?
- She is here.
- [Kelly] Your mom is
here? Is she right here?
- She is here. Oh, she's waving.
- [Kelly] What's up mama?
(audience applauding )
- So how is she doing so far, mom?
- Well, I mean, she's here,
so the text obviously works
and I'm just in awe.
(laughs)
- [Kelly] Exactly, it's
working, the plan is working.
- Totally.
- Um, so, Malia, was your
mom always encouraging
of your acting or was she a little scared?
Because as a mama, I
would be a little scared.
- [Malia] Yeah, for sure.
I mean, there's always gonna
be those doubts, kind of,
and those fears in the back of you mind.
There's insecurities as well,
but she was really
supporting from the start.
You know, my family has
being my biggest supporter,
which I feel like getting
into this industry
is the one thing that you need.
- [Kelly] Amen.
- But she gave me one year to the date
of, you know, being able
to drive to the city,
because I live on a farm.
So, drive to the city,
which is like an hour plus away
and do auditions and
if it didn't work out,
then it didn't work out,
and I was understanding of that.
But a year to the date,
I picked up Babysitter's
Club and here I am.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- Yeah.
(audience applauds)
- On Netflix! That's amazing.
- [Kelly] So, wait. Now you're
on the Babysitter's Club.
Way to go for that year deal.
That worked out.
So, does your character deal with,
like, a lot of the same things
that you feel like you deal
with in your life?
- Yeah, I mean, there's that
kinda like teen awkwardness
that we both go through.
I mean, I always joke about we practically
went through puberty on Netflix
and I feel like that's very-
- That's rough.
- It was rough, you know, with everything.
So figuring out how to
navigate friends, and school
and social life,
and I had my first kiss
on the series as well, so-
- [Kelly] What?
- [Malia] Yeah!
- [Kelly] Wait, your
first kiss was at work?
- With all the producers
that flew down from LA
for that specific scene,
so yes, that was interesting.
- Oh, my gosh! People were watching?
That's weird.
Your first kiss.
My first kiss was horrible though.
So, you know?
- [Hasan] Malia, you are so brave.
You're talking about this in front of mom.
(audience laughs)
- [Malia] She was
videotaping the whole thing!
- This is bad parenting.
- Thank you!
(audience laughs)
- You need to be like Indian parents.
We don't talk about it.
The first time I kissed
was when Beena and I got married.
(audience laughs)
- [Hasan] The way God intended, mom.
We didn't just kiss for
SAG after residuals.
Do you understand?
(audience laughs)
- We kissed for something
deeper, like love.
- No, you can't count that though
because I did have, like, a stage kiss
in musical theater growing up.
I didn't count that as
like a first, you know.
- True, exactly, you know?
- It counts.
- [Kelly] No!
- Malia, it counts.
- No.
- All right guys, we're
not gonna have a debate
about this now.
- I just call that homework
until the real thing happens.
The real test happens.
- Its a little like test, for sure,
and then the fourth and the fifth,
and then many takes of that happens.